okay goodbye are you ready it's not the
sorry waited I was like hood what is the
most deadliest rue this we're doing sad
cringe sad cringe every Sammy real it's
a develop acquired taste
- appreciate truly a sad cringe can it
is it like you know wheat you cry you
lose kind of thing and this is a you cry
you win okay
yes YouTube so we're here to review the
sad cream so Brady I'm ready this one is
from 8-bit and 16-bit retro gamers so
hey everyone I am in immediate need of
hell
so back at beginning of summer I bought
around 6000 fidgets spinners at a
wholesale to resell what a great
investment Wow only 6000 of them
let's see how many did it sell I just
only sold 73 of them wow that's cool it
only needs to sell 5927 more quick maths
does anyone want to buy some in bulk
what about you kid you want to buy some
in bulk I just can't wait what an
investment I'm getting desperate
I suck my life saving it to that oh you
know I look at Bitcoin and I'm like no
thank you
I will spend all my life savings in
fidget spinners who knows maybe in 20
years they'll come back yeah yeah like
pogs or something
yeah box hook came back that was a sad
cringe that was the sad cream Happy New
Year thanks cutie want to know a secret
I actually never had a New Year's kiss
may I kindly offer you to be my first
[Music]
no reply no reply just humiliated on
reddit and said but dick moon I think
about it hey baby me you know what not
poor Ethan he's gonna have to die I'm
sorry
then suppose it's on my page send your
snapchat name to me please
I adds you let's snapchat text me on it
text me on snapchat I'm already feeling
pretty thirsty an hour passes all right
not even an hour 20 minutes this is Josh
mom he just ran in front of a car
oh no and I don't know he was gonna make
it he was a bleed from his mouth oh no
oh no not the bleed from his mouth he
could die at any second that's a mu
damage bleeding from your mouth and said
he loves everybody but I don't know if
he's going to make it and he loves you
do you care about him do you care about
him hi it's Josh now just got back from
the hospital
please snapchat can you send me snapchat
please well you know a plus for trying
he just ran in front of a car and get
the snapchat it's not worth living
divorcee selfie yeah the woman in the
back sling
that's a cringe window come on yeah it's
not a sad cringe he looks like he's
happy about it so I'm sure he's winning
hey exactly the dirtiest job be furry
artists make about $250 each Commission
and it takes me three days to do one
wait a minute
$250 why are we here three days to work
Jesus patron has given me over 4k a
month just to post my commissions
they're not even that well-known they
don't even know me and I'm making 4k a
month plus $250 every three days vomit
about 5 to 6 times we're making these
Commission because I find freaking
disgusting this is exactly what it's
like to do you - Wow I'm just saying you
should go to prom with me in the trash
can basis so saying friend
zone so hard we look so much like a
couple here hahahahaha a couple of best
did an escape room with all my female
co-worker I was stuck in a small room
with three females for 58 minutes why
don't you say an hour they smelled so
good and we touched heads so much I
literally feel hi oh my god it was 58
minutes of ecstasy I'm in heaven
every room becomes an escape room with
name I did an escape room for the first
time a few a week ago or something like
that and with no one touched hands okay
no one needed to touch any hand how's
this guy reactively like shake someone's
hand that's a female
it's like when you hug a girl when
you're you're a kid and you're like I
feel something there this poor guy and
his ex-girlfriend Mike's girlfriend
bought this on my account I'm still hurt
from the break-up but Amazon is bugging
me about a review so here I am lurking
her Instagram to see the outfit man you
know I was unable to see in person she
looks great in this two-piece and it
fits every curve just I could just
imagine all the attention she's getting
in this although I'm sad I'm very happy
she made this purchase man boy stop
sympathize a can this ex-girlfriend
bought it on his account yeah well what
do you think she's got her money
connected to that account
hey no yeah but oh oh my okay so this is
what shows up if you search Google on
Bing why go there when you can search
here you can search right here try it
please
to be fair every time I've ever searched
anything on being it's never giving me
what I want
really I have to go to like the second
page on being to find what I want and
that's just asking too much I never even
tried there you go well now I know I
never will have to try this woman got
stuck in her bathtub for 30 minutes
after bathing and coke
there's no traction no grip just me and
my fat body slippery huh covered in oil
must read like the quote they took just
me and my fat body sitting around
covered in oil as a news story did you
just tweet her or something she must had
like call the police I'm stuck in my
bathtub I can't get out this is what I
mean like sorry you lost it you life is
over now I would like to thank everyone
for a lovely birthday messages oh wait I
don't I didn't get any ha ha ha ha ha
let's say you know somebody's sad cringy
because they go I thought you just call
me out because I didn't send you
birthday wishes what a good cringy
moment there I I freaking put your name
in my calendar so I can congratulate you
on your birthday and I didn't even get
anything on my birthday and the only
reply I got from your birthday was like
oh you check Facebook no I did oh you
know who's never getting a happy
birthday ever
I know your birthday was coming up so I
Google a hey you what yep I am just got
home from work
nice how was that it was okay I guess
yeah so with why are you tired what
don't um me you I was big very polite
and you just ignore me your last just
got home I wanna know how long it took
for that to come back
by you tight like I need it she'll lol
you were texting before wow you have no
idea on what you're gonna miss out on
miss out a tinge of pleasure down the
drain don't try to play hard-to-get now
it's over
I'll see you it's over what does I mean
I'll see you in there as well okay sure
beautiful so good tonight Tim saw your
1k donation to her on last stream that's
crazy bro I'm still below top ten
donators haha okay squad bro I need 1k
donation please donate a little less
this month because four months of rent
we're overdue but I still got to do it
oh oh if I give a money they love me
yeah man I get it my wife's been bugging
me about this holiday but the squad
comes first look that's the next level
brainwashing right there this is
recently three days ago Jesus Christ
like how much it would be fellas save if
they just did two bits well you gotta be
tough it's for the squad for the squad
fam all right I think that's it thank
you Ken four sad cringing with me that
was beautiful I feel terrible I feel
good this is what I'm this gives me
strength this gives me power do you feed
off the sand cringe people's back in
consuming their souls you know check out
Ken's channel everybody in case of him
please drop some 1k donations they I
know he does live streams
stop asking about the broken podcast
please thank you bye